e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
bom você e que está uma delícia é você
já deve saber por que fazem várias
maneiras de começar esse vídeo porque
afinal é sempre importante você fazer
igual a esse programa de tv que rola pra
carai ficar falando muito antes de
mostrar como hoje nós vamos conhecer a
história de uma placa uma certa placa
que veio de um certo lugar e esta placa
dá porque já já eu sei que tá um carro
vai ficar essa taxa já tem que ficar em
casa vai conhecer a história dessa troca
mas antes a gente vai falar dos novos
boletos na minha frente eu não gosto
desse tipo de coisa esse é o tipo de
problema que quando eu assisto muito
canal do boi manda ninguém assiste ou
seja usar aplique beit que aqueles
título muito chamativo joguei a placa de
10 milhões na cabeça da minha mãe era
aquela morreu interrogação mas dia da
briga a pessoa clica por curiosidade ela
não tem mãe no ea idade lá e pra cá eu
resolvi fazer normal e mostrar lá mas
antes vamos falar dos novos bonito olha
que beleza e olha que bonito
olha que beleza olha que delícia e atrás
tem volumes e dá pra ver um grande
estúdio de gravação né atrás tem windows
phones congratulations four suporta
andré melhor seus quadros
é o teu
op
pega essa placa segurada em mãos eu só
tenho uma coisa a dizer pra vocês aqui
se pegar na cabeça mata é exata vai
explicar como isso aqui é de metal e
isso aqui é o diamante entendeu não sei
se há motivo vou testar tentar repassar
um cara que vem de entrega e venda de
crack sabão peças corin oeste a última
vez que teve dengue malária eu nunca
fiquei tão lei eu só quero dizer muito
obrigado a todos vocês e isso aqui o que
é o reflexo é exatamente o que eu quero
passar pra você
comecei assim não gostaram assim eu
continue assim até ganhar isso aqui é
isso aí olha que bonitinha tinha mais
saidinho tudo que eu não sei ler em
inglês junto é de recife
também no dia 10 dia 10 teatro
guararapes em recife agora por ter
ouvido as olimpíadas em outubro viu pra
ninguém só quem assistiu o vídeo foi que
ele segue no facebook segue no instagram
o seguinte ó ataque wilson nunes disse
que tem um negocinho azul aqui treinando
sozinho uma bolinha azul e você vai
clicar nele você vai clicar em seguindo
e vai colocar em ver primeiro esse aqui
do lado entendeu por você abre seu
facebook vai estar lá em cima e depois
quase nada então não vai atrapalhar
aparecesse aqui ao vídeo dos ac dc pela
ao postar um vídeo novo desse jeito a 21
do total você vai ser o primeiro a
receber porque eu posso logo no facebook
pra dar aquela moral daquela curtinho
aqui você não me segue no instagram é
esse que aparece na tela unidas onu está
chegou aqui não está ganha destaque a
fotinha da placa hta o rabo e utah que
vai fazer você vem aqui no cantinho da
tela aqui o que coloca em ativar
notificações de publicação aqui ó
pronto você vai colocar aqui em ativar
ataque é que acontece eu não posso quase
nada porte com a foto por dia então toda
vez que o portal foto vai fazer pão isso
postou uma foto você vai ver que vê o
dica é assistir quando um suicida eu
posto aqui olha aí o pessoal fica o
posto um vídeo entender então você nunca
perde o vídeo é isso aí faço e sei que
você
vai perder um vídeo novo eu acho que
amanhã ou depois de amanhã já tem vídeo
novo muito obrigado a assistir se viu
até aqui o esquece não gostei que vocês
sempre esquece quando vamos sair daqui
seis fechada bom assistir o vídeo dá
gosto explica que gostei volta lá no
facebook que me segue no facebook de
novo minha placa e 10 milhões nova basta
clicar em curtir se a gente continuar
assim vai conseguir ser o maior canal do
brasil e vão continuar subindo e muito
obrigado pela ajuda muito obrigado está
sempre comigo é de belo horizonte show e
no dia 23 deste mês a aparecer na data
aqui na tela onde comprar um ingresso
muito obrigado amo jogar no youtube isso
aqui é nosso é muito importante pra mim
isso aqui é uma coisinha pequenininha
meio de tanta coisa a gente vai
conseguir que vai ganhar a guarda e que
tem muita coisa legal aí é nóis